hello my name is david hanson here
international representative road
earlier foundation based in Santiago
Chile today I want to answer what I
think is the biggest untapped resource
in Latin America and that's about really
percent of Latin Americans who have so
much more latent opportunities and power
to get for more effective more powerful
lives the revenue model helps him to do
this the road earlier model is flexible
cost-effective self-sustaining and
extremely effective wherever families
are committed to improve their lives and
their destinies working with the private
public and several sites of the society
sectors of society and the association
with the World Economic Forum who enjoy
the mitotic we are in a position to help
countless thousands more families
wherever you may be located to undertake
improve your lives in your destination
to find out more about where Leo and his
visit us f through web site
www.illnoisedg.com